wir sprechen jetzt mit nikolaus schär er
ist abgeordneter im nationalrat war bis
juni parteivize dort also ein großes
tier sozusagen heilig neos bei den
liberalen stimmten sonntag gehen
herzlich willkommen bei bit live schönen
guten tag haben sie in österreich gerade
ihren beliebtesten und ihren größten
politik star kanzlers da im handumdrehen
erledigt
ich glaube dass wir sehen ist dass hier
ein korruptes system und das ist genau
das was dieses system kurz im endeffekt
war wo sich jemand mit stahl geld zuerst
seine partei gekauft hat und dann mit
gefälschten und manipulierten umfragen
darüber hinaus auch noch mit inseraten
kollektion eine wahl gekauft hat dass
dieses system bröckelt und ich halte das
für wichtig und das ist jetzt der tag 0
wo wir endlich aufhören müssen mit
diesem korrupten system und zuerst haben
wir schauen müssen dass wir dieses
sümpfe die hoffentlich da sind auch
entsprechend trocken legen glauben sie
wirklich dass da ein rücktritt von
sebastian kurz tatsächlich reicht um
diese sümpfe wie sie sie nennen
trockenzulegen
das glaube ich auf gar keinen fall will
wir haben eher eine rochade geschehen
und nicht weitere das system kurz bleibt
genauso am schalthebel der macht wie es
der fall gewesen ist haben wir einen
neuen bundeskanzler war sebastian kurz
wird krugman die fraktionsführer im
parlament und hat weiterhin genau das
ist gleich das system auch mit seiner
ministerinnen und minister in der
bundesregierung
und genau das ist ja dass auch hier ist
leos kritisieren dass das kernbank sein
kann weil wir wirklich das system
entsprechend beenden müssen dieses
system dieses gelübde system der
inseraten korruption das system wo
umfang manipuliert werden wo steuergeld
man das ist ja christ gravierender hier
wird das steuergeld der
österreicherinnen und österreicher wurde
dafür verwendet von sebastian kurz und
seinen vertrauten um ihn größer zu
machen um ihn an die macht putschen und
das ist ein unfassbarer skandal aber
herr scherf sie hätten mit den eos am
dienstag mitgestimmt beim
misstrauensvotum gegen sebastian kurz
was haben sie sich erwartet was dann
passiert ich meine da hätte ja nur das
chaos gewartet im anschluss nein nein
das glaube ich gar nicht also wenn sie
von trauer sprechen dann müssen sie sich
das system kurz anschauen das ist das
was gebracht hat nach österreich
so wenn ich das erste mal dass sebastian
kurze chaos bringt er hat zwei
regierungen gesprengt jetzt hat er
dieses chaos verursacht das momentan in
österreich herrscht also was möglich
gewesen wäre ist das mit stabilität in
das land hineinbringen dass endlich
schluss ist mit diesem material system
mit diesem system kurz und das chaos
bringt eindeutig
daher und sebastian kurz in dem wie sie
die letzten jahre immer wieder agiert
java ist ein kurzzeit riesigen rückhalt
in seiner eigenen partei und hat auch
weiterhin recht großen rückhalt so hören
wir hier zumindest in deutschland bei
den österreichern selbst kapieren die
das nicht dass das wie sie sagen ein so
korruptes system ist oder haben die am
ende rechts die mehrheit der
österreicher in dem sie einen sehr
populären sebastian kurz unterstützt
also ich glaube dass die österreichische
bevölkerung genauso schockiert ist wie
ich dass sie jemand sich über jahre
hinweg mit ihrem steuergeld an die macht
geputscht und nichts anderes war aus und
ja vielleicht dauert das noch ein paar
tage bis es überall angekommen ist aber
es ist wie gesagt ein system dass
niemand gutheißen kann und sie kennen
das das in anderen ländern dass sowas
auch ein bisschen dauert bis es überall
angekommen ist und weil sie den rückhalt
in der eigenen partei angesprochen haben
in wag ich einigermaßen zu bezweifeln
und wenn der rückhalt so stark gewesen
wäre dann wären wohl noch über
bundeskanzler und hätte nicht diese
rochade vollzogen haben und ich bin
gespannt was in den nächsten tagen und
wochen noch mehr rauskommen wird aber
diese jets sind ja maximal die spitze
des eisberges dieses systems und wir
werden sehen wo noch auf anderen ebenen
perverser korruptes verhalten dargelegt
wurden wo vielleicht sonst noch in
salaten korruption getätigt wurde das
heißt ich glaube es ist nur eine frage
der zeit ist dieses system so wichtig zu
bröckeln anfang und am schluss auch
[Musik]